à la foire la brquante il y a plein de
Bul qui me
tent sousmarins nucléaire et quelques
missil
sola une ruine de cyclotron une anombe à
neutron ça n'est vraiment pas cher c'est
bien crader plein de
poussière je collectionne les résidus t
les temps perdus les gpill les gâ le
d'AP Go tout
ça
à la fois rose 20 chef d'État en
Paillé la grim au gamin ça fait àyer mon
chien des sabres des goupillons une
douzaine
d'échantillons j'aime comme je les aime
bouffés par les
charançons
je collectionne les résidus t les temps
perdu lesp les gâ dans le profond
d'AP qu'on a go tout
ça tout
ça703 j'ai de têtes et qu
bras mon voisin une queue de lapin mais
ici personne se
PL mant t c'est machin de la foire la
brocante le Pass qui déc et cou de B on
s'en
souvient je collectionne les résidus
tous les temps perdus les
gaspill
ça com tout ça
ouais
Paul person